we are going to Mars one day and we know
that even if the technology is ready
we'll be a no go for launch because the
human body and the human systems are not
ready we have Scott Kelly and his
Russian counterpart Mikhail Kornienko
who have been onboard the space station
for almost a year they're getting ready
to come back on March 1st a one-way trip
to Mars is at least six to eight months
so it's really important for us to
understand how the human body adapts
beyond six months for Scott and Mikkel
they have become subjects for us to test
what happens to the human body eight to
twelve months while it's in space
astronauts will come back and they weigh
much less than than when they went up so
we know that with the muscle atrophy and
the bone density loss they are losing
one and a half percentage of bone a
month which is equivalent to what a
postmenopausal woman loses in a year we
found that exercising every day doing
high resistive exercise proper nutrition
and some vitamin D supplements actually
reverse the effects of bone density so
there's a lot we can learn so that we
are successful in sending humans on a
journey to Mars one day we found very
recently that their vision decreases as
a result of fluid shifting towards the
head in a non gravitational environment
and then that swells some of the optic
nerves causing a decrease in vision and
so it's really important to understand
what are some of the things we can do to
counteract that there's an investigation
now that Scott and his counterpart
Mikkel is going through called fluid
shifts and that is using a pants we call
the chillest
which sucks the fluid back down towards
the legs and we are hoping to find that
that would counteract some of the vision
impairment losses
they are seeing they're subjected to
radiation of course the space station is
not always shielded from radiation so
there are some radiation exposure
effects their heart shrinks as a result
of not being able to have the heart pump
blood towards the feet because they're
not walking they're floating and so
Scott and Mikkel
during this one-year mission is really
our first adventure in finding out what
happens and how we can counteract the
human adaptations for a long journey to
Mars